[Música]
boa tarde a todos
o pessoal se criança é muito massa é
todo mundo lembra daquela fase legal
sempre mail a e voltou a histórias e
aventuras descobrimentos onde a gente
fazia coisas que muitas vezes não eram
esperadas da gente
quem não teve um brinquedo aqui muito
legal que ficou muito quando era novo
mas assim que ele começou a quebrar
ficou mais legal ainda que começou a
colocar novas peças a colar a desmontar
de um brinquedo viraram dois de três
viraram vocês começaram a transformar
aqueles brinquedos de vocês de uma forma
muito intuitiva é muito gostosa
tá e aquilo ali era muito legal quem é
que não fez isso em casa também há muito
tempo atrás esse moleque também fui eu o
adorava fazer isso daí
e às vezes nem somente com os brinquedos
às vezes com resíduos que os atos não
gostavam mais lixo brincam embalagens
frascos tudo ganhava uma vida nova na
mão das crianças
isso era muito gostoso e uma das coisas
que mais gostava de fazer quando moleque
era voltar pra casa que em casa era um
ambiente onde eu conseguia construir
fazer da vida essas novas coisas que eu
tinha que eu tinha em mãos e na escola
não eu sempre fui um aluno mediano
chegava lá eu precisava sentar ouvir
decorar deposto era testado quanto de
cor ou aquilo ali não era instruídos e o
meu grande prazer como um condição assim
meio introvertido pouco social feinho
magrelo
só me restava para casa e brincar era
minha grande diversão e chegando lá não
adianta somente construir por construir
aquilo ali tudo aquilo era parte de uma
grande aventura de uma grande missão dos
comandos em ação ou dos bonecos do email
que estavam lá sem um braço sem uma
perna a cabeça trocada tava tudo
invertido aquilo ali era tudo muito
gostoso muito caótico muito livre
nós fizemos o que dava na cabeça
tínhamos liberdade de criar e tudo isso
durou até os meus 14 anos pessoal aos 14
anos
faz uma confissão aqui para vocês foi
nesse momento que eu aprendi a aprender
antonini a minha oitava série a partir
daí tem início a um curso
profissionalizante entrei nessa aventura
do mundo técnico também então fui
aprender eletrônica durante todo o meu
dia e à noite ainda fazia o ensino médio
em uma escola pública na periferia de
são paulo
então cresci nos próximos dois anos
desenvolvendo os muitos projectos
aprendendo pra caramba muita coisa dura
técnica matemática física química mas de
uma forma muito aplicada mesmo muita
bagunça muita molecada muita mulher
cagen dentro da escola técnica e neste
momento as coisas começaram a fazer
sentido a gente não decorava por decorar
eu aprendi uma técnica aprendia algo da
física e aplicava uma construção nova e
aquilo ali parece que abriu um mundo pra
nós tá
as coisas precisam ser práticas possam
ser aplicadas e muitas vezes quando a
gente aprendia e aplicava vinha junto a
isso a aplicação da criatividade não
bastava replicar a teoria tudo precisava
criar algo novo botar aquilo expressar
aquilo é aquele fantástico
foram dois anos incríveis meus 15 e 16
anos onde eu passava intensamente o dia
inteiro dessa escola era uma escola que
eu não pagava então era bolsista durante
a noite e fazia o ensino médio em uma
escola pública na periferia de são paulo
também e lá bate os conhecimentos que já
tava vendo durante o dia e o tempo foi
passando e no fim desse curso a nossa
expectativa era caras quando a gente sai
daqui e vai ser todo mundo otoni está
kinect vai revolucionar o mundo e vai
criar coisas incríveis todos os
problemas acabaram vamos salvar a áfrica
vão salvar todo mundo está afeito a
resolver os problemas
só que do outro lado era um ano de
estágio obrigatório da indústria e essa
nossa expectativa se concluíram não há
nesse ambiente industrial no qual nós
nos deparamos a primeira coisa que nos
deram foi um uniforme uniforme azul um
tá com o nome da empresa no peito em uma
fila a fila para bater o dedo fila
pra comer fila para receber e no
banheiro era feio bb aguarda sinal de
competência tinha que receber um comando
e replicá lo do modo mais rápido e
perfeito possível tudo tudo cronometrado
tudo seqüenciado tudo segmentado tudo
especializada e aquelas coisas ali
começaram a entrar em choque com as
nossas expectativas puxa era isso que a
gente queria
em geral falo por mim mas há uma visão
geral dessa turma nossa formado ele não
fazia sentido eu lhe fazer muito mais
sentido para máquinas do que pra pessoas
está uma linha de produção todos iguais
todos em face da era muito angustiante
ver aquele momento ali e foi apenas
alguns meses
esses meses que se passaram acabaram
colocando nos colocando em um loop
infinito dia após dias de receber um
comando uma ordem replicar a construir
voltar fazer tudo novamente tudo
novamente tudo novamente
pessoal o mundo viveu três grandes
revoluções tá nossa
quando falo mundo na nossa sociedade
humana é segundo os teóricos a primeira
grande foi a revolução agrícola onde a
política né onde o homem deixou de ser
nossos antepassados deixaram de ser
coletores e caçadores básicos nômades
pra começar a entender como a natureza
funcionava e cultivá la plata começar a
cuidar dos animais começaram a circular
portar como uma pequenas comunidades
fixas em prol do que em proteger estas
famílias tivessem um pouco mais sucesso
na luta pela sobrevivência mais sete que
se originou dentro desse processo dessa
revolução foi a fundamentação da
estrutura hierárquica e patriarcal
dentro dos sistemas familiares dentro
das estruturas onde os seres humanos se
organizava e também o sentimento de
manter tudo previsível ou seja você
precisava saber qual estação você
plantava você precisa saber qual estação
você escolheria e produto em prol da
sobrevivência previsibilidade era
sinônimo de sobrevivência de sucesso e
tudo obedecendo uma cadeia patriarcal
seja os homens da família tomavam conta
pela força que tinha e nessa cadeia de
comando e submissão
a segunda grande revolução que impactou
a humanidade e alguns milênios depois
foi a chegada da máquina a vapor
revolução industrial está neste momento
as estruturas das famílias que
anteriormente eram muito altos entradas
elas conseguiam se resolver pequenas
comunidades familiares
agora tem um novo viés os indivíduos da
família precisam diversificar as suas
fontes de renda começa a migração e prol
dos centros urbanos então as indústrias
empresas estabelecem mas muito daquele
+7 agrícola permanece o a hierarquia
patriarcal nenhum nome mais bonitão
agora é o organograma tá toda aquela
estrutura de previsibilidade agora
também ganha uma nova visão agora
previsibilidade não basta simplesmente
saber quando chega o verão quando vai
chover quando chega o inverno muito bom
ou excelente na terra
agora vem por meio do controle agora é
feito por meio da segmentação e por meio
do dda ordem estava em por meio da
repetição da constância e esse processo
todo se durou nos últimos cento e poucos
anos até nos depararmos ultimamente na
revolução no qual nós estamos inseridos
hoje que é justamente a revolução
digital ta com a proposta com a rápida
propagação das tecnologias
acessibilidade a elas essa nossa nova
geração que já nasceu com wifi bombando
por aí né
o bebê sair da barriga da mãe em vez de
chorar pede a senha tá então ele está
num outro mundo as cabeças mudaram os
mesmos comportamentos mudaram esse
processo de mudança comportamental
acabou fazendo com que o que muitos dos
paradigmas industriais e agrícolas que
nós herdamos quando a gente fala
industrial e agco não quer dizer que um
só acontece no campo e outro acontece na
indústria são comportamentos que nós
temos como a sociedade está entraram em
choque porque essa nova geração começou
a ter coisas mais instantâneas começou a
não ver mais sentido em obedecer
estruturas muito hierarquias muito duras
porque esse pensamento especialmente
wifi e pensamento digital tudo é muito
instantânea tudo muito rápido tudo é
muito fácil tem acesso a tudo e isso deu
mais liberdade para os indivíduos
voltarem a sonhar mais ea criar mais
com isso dessa revolução digital vem por
meio do que vem por meio de indivíduos
mais empoderadas na sua capacidade de
criar e desenvolver e se expressar com a
capacidade de construir também tá que
esse mundo digitalizado nos forneceu
eles começaram a fazer o quê
resgatar aquelas competências que eles
tinham quando eram crianças ou seja
explorar o mundo de forma mais livre só
que agora com as competências como que a
era industrial nos forneceu que o
controle que é o pragmatismo a entrega
do resultado tangível e essa mistura de
controle liberdade divergência e
convergência causa e ordem trouxe novo
mais cética justamente uma de 7 calote
porque é como a natureza funciona ela se
organiza dessa forma existe caos existe
ordem e isso se complementa e se entrega
como um todo e à aplicação prática
dessas espécies desses novos pensamentos
têm fazendo com que fiquem fazendo com
que novos negócios e novas carreiras
surjam tá em prol dessa dessa revolução
é um mundo totalmente novo no qual nós
estamos passando por isso agora e aquele
que a atividade acaba sendo um grande
entrave desse potencializador de
revolução
ok mas quem é que está inserido nisso
daí não estão falando especificamente de
designers e arquitetos profissionais da
economia criativa isso estava sendo
válido para todo mundo
estamos falamos aqui de secretárias de
cabelos de padeiros de vendedores e
todos aqueles que conseguiram se
apropriar tá dessa nossa nova cultura
digital desses novos comportamentos que
diferentemente das áreas agrícolas e
industriais nos permitiram a ter essa
liberdade de construir e criar e essa
capacidade de construir e criar tatá
muito relacionado que conquanto você
pratica essas atividades criativas no
seu dia a dia
tá aqui vem um mito muito claro muito
clássico de quando a gente trata de
criatividade é justamente que se isso é
coisa de artista isso é coisa de quem
tem um dom ou se isso é coisa é questão
de prática de vivência de construção
durante o seu processo de evolução como
ser humano
no primeiro momento
no primeiro momento pode parecer que que
essa relação está muito direcionado à
nossa formação
mas alguns pesquisadores como os como
anders ericsson é um pesquisador muito
focado em comunicação nos apresenta
algumas teorias comanda as 10 mil horas
no qual dez senhoras é um número mais
com o número necessário no qual os
nossas habilidades por mais banais que
sejam possam ser reconhecidas como um
talento
tá essas 10 mil horas fazendo uma conta
de padeiro uma conta muito rápido aqui
seriam oito horas por dia durante três
anos tá ou três horas por dia durante
dez anos
tudo depende de quanto você vai se
dedicar a fazer isso daí
aqui se coloca em prática aquela
diacrítico ditado que talento é 1%
inspiração e 99% transpiração
você precisa construir isso na sua base
diária e pessoal e no quesito
criatividade
todos nós aqui já cumprimos a nossa cota
de 10 mil horas em criatividade todos
tá quem é que conseguiu brincar quando
criança
tá brincando até os nove anos nem quanto
aos seus dez anos 12 13 e 14 com precoce
você precisou largar essa a diversão de
brincar de imaginar criar de se
expressar livremente
então quando crianças nós cumprimos
facilmente essa nossa cota de 10 mil
horas
mas chegou um momento da vida nós somos
instruídos está a começar nos dedicar em
outros talentos talentos um pouco mais
pragmáticos um pouco mais analíticos
talentos mais orientados a memória a
decorar coisas absorver informação e não
em construir em expressar e se
desenvolver
isso começa quando a gente começa a
estudar quando começa o período letivo
quando começa a entrar na primeira série
segundo isso vai evoluindo e os
ensinamentos vão ficando cada vez mais
complexos essas roupas complexidades
estão diretamente envolvidas com com
analítico vai ficando têm o ensino às
suas práticas
você vai deixando de lado essas
expressões criativas que tinha quando
criança
então nós começamos a dedicar mais 10
mil horas para outros talentos
aí depende de cada um é eu acho que as
minhas dez mil horas na escola não foram
tão bem
coitados assim também eu sempre tive a
notas médias nada muito relevante sempre
tirando 1 768
enfim a devia ter colocado um pouquinho
mais e horas nesse processo ele e aí vem
o desafio e se nessa pesquisa do under 0
ele percebeu que que não importa se você
fosse o michael jordan o gate os beats
tá todos eles precisaram dedicar estas
suas 10 mil horas para desenvolver esse
talento específico e esse talento
específico além de ser bem desenvolvido
com muita energia muito foco tá muita
dedicação precisava de um contexto
propício propício para que isso
acontecesse
existe um contexto propício não é
exatamente o contexto com mais sete
indústrias ao e nenhum contexto mais
sete agrícola precisa ter um mais sete
propício nesse contexto para que para
que você desenvolva suas habilidades e
os indivíduos se tornem mais empoderadas
na sua capacidade criativa e porque é
importante para nós desenvolver esse
processo de desenvolvimento e
criatividade em nosso dia a dia
à primeira vista pessoal a
desenvolvimento próprio um indivíduo que
tem mais capacidade de gerar mais
alternativas perante o seu processo de
de desenvolver seus próprios só tomada
de decisão seus caminhos a serem
seguidos consegue ser mais diferenciado
no seu ambiente de trabalho na sua
comunidade
o segundo ponto todo aquele que tem mais
capacidade de gerar alternativas mais
capacidade de trazer mais soluções para
o mundo acaba sem poder andar de uma tia
de uma do quesito muito importante que é
a liberdade
tá pra ser criativo você precisa ter uma
certa liberdade de expressar de
construir de falar tá a falta de
liberdade ea restrição disso acaba
fazendo porque o que você esteja coibido
a republica e buscar instruções de
outros está esse processo é muito
interessante porque alguns estudos na
área de desenvolvimento econômico ao
redor do mundo mostram que países onde
existe a alta liberdade dos indivíduos
em criar empreender e se expressar tá os
vintes econômicos e desenvolvimento
humano acaba sendo mais altos do que
aqui
diz que não tem aliás aqueles que não
têm acabam tendo que mais tirania mais
pobreza mas não do estado
tá mais ceticismo em relação à a visão
externa do mundo ou seja vocês existe
menos criatividade no dia a dia das
pessoas no dia a dia da comunidade no
qual ela está inserida
então o pessoal a gente pode redefinir
que criatividade justamente essa tua
liberdade de agir e de pensar e de poder
construir pelo menos pra mim é leitor
depois que eu saí da indústria da minha
experiência dentro da indústria eu
acabei buscando pra mim uma carreira no
qual pudesse conciliar a entrega de
valor e se meu pensamento de construção
com criatividade
eu acabei escolhendo designer não
somente pela capacidade de desenvolver
novos produtos e serviços mas pelo
potencial dele despir as pessoas
acreditarem no seu na sua confiança
criativa no seu no seu potencial
criativo como agente ativo transformador
na comunidade
eu espero hoje ter dado mais um passo em
direção a esse objetivo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]